John Stewart is returning to the Daily
Show I barely remember when John Stewart
took over The Daily Show I just
mentioned uh watching South Park as a
kid in the 90s in the 90s Comedy Central
was a very small TV channel and South
Park was this Juggernaut that really
made it a big deal and there was another
show that was pretty big for Comedy
Central standards not compared to South
Park but but by the standards of this
cable network which was The Daily Show
and it was hosted by Craig kilborne and
it was a funny show and then John
Stewart took it over in 99 or
something and he made it a big deal not
really among viewers but among the media
the ratings were always relatively low
for the Daily Show but the right kind of
people watched it people who were
working in the media would watch it and
so he got way outside's press coverage
he had a way bigger influence on
politics it became a real cultural
phenomenon I watched that show a bunch
when I was a kid he's very funny
comedian John
Stewart and then he created all these
spin-offs the Steven coar show and John
Oliver and all these other people and it
was it it had a lot of influence and
then the moment John Stewart left that
show it completely went to pot no one
really talked about it anymore they gave
the show to Trevor Noah he was a total
flop in that position now I don't even
know who the host is I think they just
have a a rotating cycle of hosts and and
now he's back he's coming back as an
executive producer of the show and he's
going to host the show one night a week
why why do I care again not that not
even that many people watched it back
when it was a big popular
show the significance of this story is
that it reminds
us the Democrats have nothing new the
Democrats have nothing exciting to look
forward to the Democrats the Liberals
broadly peaked in the late 2000s that
was Peak popular lib Democrat American
politics end of bush everyone's angry at
Bush Obama's coming up he's a good-look
guy and he's the first black president
and he gives speeches that impress some
people not me but some people and yeah
wow hopeing change and none of that
worked out and Obama said he wanted to
fundamentally transform America because
obviously he hates America you don't
want to fundamentally transform
something that you love so he succeeded
largely in doing that and since then
it's all been on the decline since then
you had Obama Obama's economy was still
terrible he divided the country he did
win re-election but then just after
Trump you had a huge reaction or just
after Obama you had a huge reaction
against him in the form of Donald Trump
uh the left has not
recovered H how could they what's their
new idea we're going to flood the
country with more illegals we're gonna
We what's the new idea we're going to
oppose War what are you talking about
Barack Obama bombed more countries than
George Bush
did the world order got much shakier
here under Obama than it did even under
Bush well we're going to we're going to
stop you know just subsidizing the rich
what are you talking about Democrats are
the party of the Rich and Republicans
are the party of deplorables and
irredeemables and bitter clinging white
trash that you all absolutely condemn
and have nothing but disdain for well
yeah okay that's true well we're the
we're the what we're the what you got
nothing you got nothing guys and so the
best they can do is is drag this poor
man out of retirement and put him back
in The Daily Show chair and try to
capture the magic magic's gone baby so
because they're not going to get that
spark back the only thing the Democrats
can do is tighten their grip on power
when you have a popular political
movement and you have cohesion and you
have a Clear
Vision you can afford a looser grip on
power because people just all kind of
know what they're doing and they just
naturally do it and they go in the right
direction and they vote for the
candidates you want them to vote for and
they support the policies you want them
to support when the ruling class and the
people people are at odds with one
another and increasingly at odds then
the ruling class has to tighten that
grip on power they have to erect all
sorts of fences around the capital and
around the White House and meanwhile
they're tearing down the fences at the
southern border which is part of the
reason the people hate the leaders in
charge or at the very least we're very
frustrated with them you got to start
arresting Midwestern Granny's for taking
selfies on January 6 the worst day ever
you got to start throwing the leader of
the opposition into prison you got to
start Prosecuting him you got to start
sending federal troops down to the
border to stop States from exercising
their constitutional right to protect
themselves you got you got to really
tighten that grip on Power and we're in
January of 2024 okay we're in January
and there are four prosecutions against
the leader of the opposition and Joe
Biden is contemplating sending the Army
in to physically remove the Texas
National Guard and open up a pathway for
foreigners to invade what day is it it's
January
25th we we got 10 more months of this
before the
election and we've got 11 more months in
the
year there is no sign that any of this
is going to loosen up we had our first
constitutional crisis Before the War
Began the prosecutions we had our second
constitutional crisis in the first month
of the year can you
imagine what the next months hold
Democrats
say that it is us not the people sending
in the troops to open the border to
flood the country with it with
foreigners no no no it is us we
conservatives who want to defend even
the basic rule of law we are the threat
to
democracy when Trump said this is not
typical he is exactly right this is not
a typical election and there's a massive
effort to normalize this you see the New
York Times column say well the Trump
people have a case you see the head of
JP Morgan Chase the largest bank in the
United States saying well they they're
right about some things you see
reporters with uh Jason Miller in the
Fort De mo hotel reminds me of a bunch
of German reporters in some Munich uh
bar in 1935 saying hey Goring he was an
entertaining guy I tell you what he had
some great stories nothing is normal
about this at all and you watched his
speech last night it was completely
unhinged and what I am obsessed with is
stop treating him like he is a normal
candidate that this is some kind of Bobo
Mitt Romney this is really not stop
treating Trump like he's normal three
big points in carville's ranti here and
James Carville is a major figure among
the Democrat political class first point
Trump's a
Nazi could you imagine at a bar in
Munich with the Nazis it's just like
that he's a Nazi wow really brilliant
you're you're you're making me see
Donald Trump in a whole new and
interesting light wow what brilliant
commentary James Carville good grief
that one you can dismiss that second one
we got to stop treating Trump like he's
normal he's not normal we got to stop
treating him like he's
normal the man was the president of the
United
States already he's already been the
Pres he's normalized he's normal the man
has been a major American public figure
for over 40
years the man endorsed Mitt Romney that
candidate who you suddenly have a
strange new respect for and that was a
big to-do when he did that in 2012 and
he was already the president he's he's
normal if he's not normal than what is
these are the people who say that
chopping off the genitals of a little
child that's perfectly normal but the
man who was already president the
somewhat slightly more right-wing
Republican but basically just a
republican that's totally abnormal but
but he gives away the game because what
does he say there at the end he said
he's not a normal Republican like Mitt
Romney and Bob Dole what do Mitt Romney
and Bob Dole have in common that
distinguishes them from Donald Trump
they lost that's look I I like Bob Dole
but that's it that's what they mean when
when the Democrats promote normal
Republicans they promote people who lose
because no in the normal operation of
events in Democrats Minds Republicans
are supposed to lose because they're
wrong they're supposed to present a
facade of opposition a simulacrum of
real opposition and political choice but
then at when push comes to shove at The
crucial moment they're supposed to lose
John McCain at The crucial moment he's
supposed to vote to support Obamacare at
the at the crucial moment they're
supposed to just cave and defend Liz
Cheney she might vote with Trump a lot
of the time but at The crucial moment
when political power is really in play
she's got a side with Nancy Pelosi
that's that's normal Mitt Romney he's
yeah nominate him and he's going to go
talk about cutting taxes and then then
the Democrats are all going to call him
a Nazi and then he's going to lose and
then they'll like him
again that's that's what's supposed to
be what's abnormal about Trump is that
he won when he wasn't supposed to and he
won with a group of Voters who were not
supposed to be owed the deplorable
irredeemable and he won on an issue that
you are absolutely never supposed to
talk about that is the mass migration
now let's call it like Abbott does an
invasion of foreigners into this country
to give Democrats and liberals permanent
political power you are you are under no
circumstances allowed to criticize that
that's that's the big threat to our
democracy suggesting that we the
American people ought to still have a
say on how our government is run huge
unacceptable threat to our democracy man
what a great clip that was now hold up
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time